en este vídeo vamos a hablar de la
plastia no muy bien vamos a hablar de la
upla ya no y en la playa no es un
operador digamos de la misma forma que
la divergencia el gradiente el
rotacional o incluso de la misma forma
que otros operadores de derivadas son
son cosas que toman funciones y nos
devuelven otra función verdad en este
caso digamos que tenemos una función
multi variable efe que depende de xy así
que puedes imaginar que esta es su
gráfica verdad más o menos es algo así
aquí tenemos el plano xy y todos estos
puntos digamos son la altura que
obtenemos al evaluar la función en cada
punto verdad así que la plastia no vamos
a denotar a la plastia no de esta forma
con este triángulo y nos va a dar una
nueva función escalar que depende de xy
de y así que esto nos devuelve una nueva
función que toma entradas en dos
dimensiones y con salidas en una sola
dimensión verdad y es como una segunda
derivada porque la forma en la que se
define es tomando la divergencia del
gradiente
en nuestra función efe así que esta es
la forma en cómo está definida la
divergencia del gradiente df y una
notación más común que podrías ver es
tomar este operador nav la verdad y
hacer el producto punto con el gradiente
de f así que si recuerda que si f es una
función escalar verdad entonces el
gradiente de f nos da un campo vectorial
y dado un campo vectorial la divergencia
de ese campo vectorial nos devuelve una
nueva función escalar verdad en este
sentido es como una segunda derivada
pero veamos si podemos entender
intuitivamente lo que esto significa
porque el gradiente nos indica la
dirección del ascenso más pronunciado
así que si tenemos el campo vectorial en
el espacio de entradas de d efe verdad y
cada uno de estos vectores apunta en la
dirección en la que deberíamos caminar
para que al ir sobre la gráfica como
digamos como una colina nos indique la
dirección en la que deberíamos
incrementar de forma más rápida a la
altura verdad y si esto quizás no te
resulta familiar deberías de checar los
vídeos que tenemos sobre gradientes y
gráficas y cómo se relacionan y en este
ejemplo específico cuando tenemos la
cima de una colina todos los puntos
alrededor de digamos la dirección en la
que deberíamos caminar es justo hacia la
cima verdad mientras que si tenemos
digamos como un valle entonces todas las
direcciones en las que deberíamos
caminar sería al incrementar la función
de forma más rápida verdad justamente
alejarnos de este valor lo que podríamos
llamar que es un mínimo local así que
vamos a quitar la gráfica vamos a
fijarnos sólo en el campo gradiente ok y
ahora vamos a pensar qué es lo que la
divergencia representa para este campo
entonces imaginamos que este campo
vectorial corresponde al flujo de
digamos agua o moléculas de aire o algo
así en cualquier momento estos digamos
se están moviendo siguiendo los vectores
a los cuales están anclados entonces por
ejemplo si tenemos esta partícula de
agua y se mueve más o menos de esta
forma siguiendo los vectores que tenemos
cerca verdad parece que termina en este
punto y eso ocurre con todas las
moléculas por aquí cerca verdad en
cambio cuando se van alejando digamos
como el caso de aquí abajo verdad este
es una este es un indicador de que la
divergencia es positiva verdad
justamente porque divergen así que en
este caso de abajo tenemos que
divergencia es positiva mientras que en
el caso anterior todas las moléculas de
agua están convergiendo hacia un punto
verdad y eso nos indica que la
divergencia es negativa y podríamos
tener otra área digamos algo más o menos
como este punto central en donde tenemos
moléculas de agua que entran pero
también están saliendo verdad y aquí
quizás no parece que entren a la misma
velocidad o quizás más lento o más
rápido pero esto más o menos podríamos
pensar que es divergencia cero así que
vamos a tratar de entender qué significa
ahora cuando hablamos de la divergencia
del gradiente así que vamos a quitar
todas estas marcas que hemos hecho vamos
a quitar todo esto y entonces ahora nos
preguntamos por qué estos vectores se
están alejando entonces si ponemos la
gráfica nuevamente las razones por qué
están apuntando hacia afuera porque
están siguiendo la dirección del ascenso
más pronunciado mientras que en el caso
contrario donde la divergencia es muy
negativa esto ocurre porque los puntos
convergen hacia el verdad y porque
convergen hacia el bueno porque el campo
gradiente nos indica cómo movernos en la
dirección en la que crece más rápido y
por lo tanto llegaríamos a la cima de la
colina en otras palabras la divergencia
del gradiente será muy alto en puntos en
donde tendremos algo como mínimos es
decir que todo alrededor de ellos tiende
a ser más alto pero la divergencia del
gradiente es baja en puntos que parecen
como máximos es decir donde alrededor de
esos puntos la función es más pequeña
entonces el operador laplace ya no es
como una medida de que tanto es un punto
un mínimo verdad y será muy positivo
cuando f evaluado en ese punto tiende a
ser un valor más pequeño que los valores
que toman f en sus vecinos verdad pero
será muy negativo cuando f evaluada en
ese punto tiende a ser más grande que
sus vecinos y esto sería digamos como el
análogo a la segunda derivada en cálculo
ordinario verdad en donde tenemos
digamos alguna especie de gráfica de una
función de una sola variable verdad y
entonces la segunda derivada de f será
muy baja será negativo en puntos donde
parece que es un máximo local pero la
segunda derivada de la función será
positiva en puntos donde se parece a un
mínimo local así que de esta forma en la
plastia no es como una especie de
análogo de la segunda derivada para
funciones multi variables escalar en el
próximo vídeo vamos a ver un ejemplo de
todo esto que hemos mencionado